Assuring privacy, and security and
trust is a necessity for digital patient
records and sharing these records
over a health information exchange.
As a result, it's an ONC Standards and
Interoperability Framework
workgroup priority area.
We’ll be looking at many S&I
workgroups as we proceed.
So it's a good idea to first
look at how they operate.
The process is intended to be grounded
in real-world issues, called use cases,
that are first identified
through an Environmental Scan.
And then molded into a consensus
document which drives
the development of standards.
Here's the workflow that surrounds the
use case of a provider ordering a lab
test, and the return of preliminary,
final, and
then corrected results back
to the ordering provider.